most of what is in your hands is in your
hands I think that the the biggest
question in life right now is whether
you decide to take responsibility for
your own actions and improve your own
life and if the answer is yes then
you're likely to be successful and if
the answer is no you're likely to be
unsuccessful it doesn't mean that there
aren't going to be problems that are
outside your control but I think that
the biggest question we all have to ask
ourselves in a free Society is how much
responsibility we wish to take today it
is a great pleasure to welcome none
other than the little known very very uh
very little known and little followed
Ben Shapiro author of the brand new book
how to destroy America in three easy
steps as you may know the podcast the in
the impossible podcast that I host is
very non-political we don't get into
anything political because I think we
have too much politics in the world we
have uh too much you know Division and
polarization and not the good kind uh of
astronomical polarization so I just want
to prepare the listeners for 30 minutes
of abject silence so we'll just sit
there we'll stare at each other I was
GNA say dude you piic you picked the
wrong guest uh so I want to start with
you uh you're known for so many things
we're going to talk about the book
hopefully uh we're also going to talk
about the many enthusiasms that you have
outside of politics because I think you
know I always say there's no red
constellations there's no blue comets uh
no one ever wakes up say I hate
astronomy you know in fact today there's
a big there's big breaking news about
possible discovery of of evidence for
life on the planet Venus uh which is a
place that's a little hotter than the
than the valley where I think you are
right now um but I want to begin with
how does bench app viw himself so if an
ATL
one of our listeners were uh were to
wake you up 3 in the morning and ask you
are you a podcaster are you an author
are you a pundit what is Ben Shapiro to
Ben Shapiro well I mean first of all a
magnificently handsome gentleman I mean
I think you have to begin with the good
looks
people maybe that's that's actually the
entire thing maybe just just an just an
incredible Apollo esque specimen of
humanity the finest that that the world
has to offer uh aside from that I mean
primarily I am a husband and a dad and
that is that is how I I identify myself
that's what I spend most of my time
worrying about and doing and then
somebody who I hope is engaged in the
world of ideas I spend an a a lot of
time trying to read on all sides of
various issues and I have a broad range
of interests I hope that I'm trying to
give impetus to people to make better
decisions in their own lives and to do
things that are meaningful to them I
think if I have one giant message
whether it's political or or life it's
it's that most of what is in your hands
is in your hands I think that the the
biggest question in life right now and
this is true politically but it's also
true personally is uh is whether you
decide to take responsibility for your
own actions and improve your own life uh
and if the answer is yes then you're
likely to be successful and uh if the
answer is no you're likely to be
unsuccessful it doesn't mean that there
aren't going to be problems that are
outside your control but I think that
the biggest question we all have to ask
ourselves in a free Society is how much
responsibility we wish to take so if I'm
an advocate for that position chiefly
then I'll be happy with that so it's
interesting you mentioned that and uh
and not being a podcaster you're
followed by millions of people you're
known for your opinions Etc but you you
essentially key into your responsibility
as a husband and a father and this takes
us somewhere where I wasn't planning to
go for a while for the next you until
about 90 minutes from now but I'll I'll
start it now uh just kidding the uh the
question I want to ask is in the in the
Bible the famous story of Adam and Eve
when they come up um it said that you
know God created uh Eve because it was
not good for man to be alone and of
course that means humanity and basically
man and women uh I want to ask you what
matured you more what caused you to be
more mature getting married or are
having or having children because if
it's not good to be alone it would seem
to me Co the Homer as they might say uh
you should have as many kids as possible
so which is more important to you you
know or which was more maturing to
maturation part of your maturation
process getting married or having
children I don't want to borrow from
from sort of an area where you are
significantly more versed than I am but
it sort of feels like Rock it feels like
rocket stages it' be it' be you know one
Builds on another I would say that that
escaping immaturity requires you to
realize that you are not the only person
in the universe and that you have to put
somebody else's interest first that
would be getting married but then
realizing there's an entire another
generation that you have to pass things
along to that you have to structure your
life in such a way as to provide a uh a
home for values uh that you really do
have to build as as we in the Jewish
Community Say by NM be you have to build
a believing household um it when when
people talk about building a household I
don't think they think about it you know
seriously enough what the language
actually means it's not just that you
create a household in which to live you
have to decide how to build you have to
decide which materials to use you have
to decide how to structure that
household and that means you have to
decide where the doors go where the
windows go how exactly people are going
to live within that household and that
means structuring your own values you
have to build yourself in order to build
the household and I think that having
kids uh yeah for for me having kids was
the culmination of a thought process
that begins when you choose to get
married so I'm of the view and I've I've
made this clear before that I think that
if people want to have successful
marriages you have to decide to get
married before you meet the person
you're going to marry mainly because if
you meet the person you're going to
marry and then you kind of fall into
marriage you may have had a very
different job description when you met
than you do when you get married when
when you're looking to get married then
you're looking for something very
different you're looking for somebody to
build that house with somebody who has
the same values you do whereas if you
fall in love with somebody it may be
that now you have to kind of jry rig the
structure that you want to live inside
because you've already you know met
somebody and you've already built a life
with this person that was kind of
accidental uh so for me it was it was
deciding to get married followed by
getting married which means that you
start to build that house and then
filling that house with children and
then adjusting the house on the Fly is
is sort of how I would think of of you
know the maturation process it's
possible to get to be single and be
selfish and just think about yourself
it's probably possible to be married and
be selfish although not for super long
because it probably won't last that long
uh but but then you have to start
thinking about the you know your moods
and and taking care of another person
potentially but it's impossible to have
children for selfish reasons I mean
nobody says at 300 in the morning I'm
really getting too much sleep I I really
like to change some diapers I mean
besides me I like to get the experience
with dark matter you know it's very
inacessible otherwise that brings up a
question I had for you is is sort of how
you structured your life it seems very
methodical I mean you've been writing
since you were 16 or or maybe even
younger you you started UCLA or bitter
Rivals to the north and uh and did you
have a plan for for how you would go
about life because we I'm a pilot people
know that um you know and it's often
said even in you know disparate Fields
like chess or whatever a bad plan beats
no plan did you have a plan and looking
back was it did your life kind of unfold
to that to that plan according to plan
or totally randomly so I would say that
I had a long-term plan like if you had
asked me when I was 16 what I wanted to
do it would actually kind of look a lot
like like what I have right now thank
god um but I I left a lot of avenues
open as to how to achieve that plan so I
think that short-term planning can be
very very difficult because there are
just too many contingencies but
long-term planning allows you to to
realize that there's play in the joints
As you move toward you know what what
you're attempting to do and so my entire
career I've I've always thought keeping
windows open having life boats ready is
is a good strategy being able to take
advantage of opportunities as they arise
as opposed to you lock yourself into one
path and now you're path dependent if
this doesn't worth you're kind of stuck
uh I've always you know tried to keep a
long-term goal in mind and then be open
to the opportunities in front of me and
try to see how those opportunities can
kind of move back and forth but in
general toward that long-term goal and
to that end do you have a a daily
routine uh how do you structure it on a
tactical level a daily level versus a
long-term strategic level that you just
laid out what's the balance life has
radically shifted since Co but before Co
I had a pretty solid daily routine I'd
wake up in the morning I would generally
wake up with the dawn because my kids
wake me up I would take care of the kids
until my wife woke up um I'd make
breakfast for them kind of review the
news on my phone while I was doing that
and then I would as soon as my wife
could take over I would go and do my
morning prayers then I would go into
work uh do do my work uh the podcast
maybe some writing come home eat lunch
take a couple of hours out to work out
uh and do some other work you know so
writing or prepping for the next day and
then it was take care of the kids for
several hours uh and then at night after
the kids go to bed usually that's when I
start to prep for the show the next day
and then it's relaxed with the wife for
a couple of hours so it's pretty
Balanced Life I would say but and and
with with kind of defined areas I do
think that it's important to Define how
you focus your time the biggest mistake
that I've made and I think people
generally make is the belief that you're
good at multitasking nobody is good at
multitasking it's just not something
people are are good at you need
dedicated amounts of time in order to
focus and that means that there's a very
funny uh but but I think true statement
that I'm trying to remember which famous
writer said this where somebody asked
them can I have five minutes of your
time he said no they said well it's just
five minutes he said right but it's not
five minutes it's it's at least 20
because you asking me the question has
now taken me out of my routine for a
certain amount of time then I have to
actually give you my attention then
after you leave I have to spend a
certain amount of time getting back into
my routine so there's no such thing as
taking five minutes out to do something
you really do have to break your time
down into significant chunks yeah that
brings up another Point your friend Sam
Harris has said at least on his podcast
that it's actually not time that's the
most precious quantity it's attention
right we all have time to watch enough
cat videos you know at least speaking
personally I'm not afraid to admit that
uh but but it's really the attention
that you just spoke about it's taking
away attention and I wonder when you
look into your you know your your
children's face your newborn and and you
say basically I'm weighing this decision
you know to to grow my following to grow
the daily wire to grow your podcast your
audience your radio you're effectively
taking time away and I I struggle with
that too how do you struggle with the
guilt you know because you you are kind
of a victim of your own success and it
has to come at some level at the cost at
the expense of of attention at least to
your family so how do you balance that
mentally are you how how do you how do
you weigh that those kind of opposite
disparate forces so I mean the good news
for me is that I've been really able to
build a terrific team here with my
business partner Jeremy boring at Daily
wire so I've been able to to Really
delegate a lot of responsibility to
people who are better at these things
than I am so I don't run my own social
media sort of presence I mean I I
obviously TW tweet and I put things on
Facebook but that's not a major part of
of my day uh and uh I'm I'm sort of
involved at a strategic level but
because our company is now so large when
we have over 100 employees I'm able to
really delegate a lot and that means
that when I focus I focus in very
specifically on what it is that I need
to do uh and then I'm able to you know
pitch in at home a lot and but this been
true for a while I've always made it a
top priority to ensure that I'm there a
lot for my kids so I've been very
involved with my kids even though I work
a lot for for you know since since they
were born and my daughter is now six um
I was actually you know sort of Chief
parental influence until probably the
last year and a half when my wife
finished residency so for for a long
time my wife was actually doing a lot
more work on an hourly basis than I was
because she was in medical residency I
would bring the kids to visit her at the
hospital she would duck out for 15
minutes come down kiss the kids I would
take them home i' get them ready for bed
uh so I I've always made this like a
real priority and that comes from my own
parents who made it a real priority
particularly my father who was was
actually home a lot more than my mom
when I was growing up um but uh I'm
lucky I've been able to structure my
days in such a way that again I wake up
with my kids I'm able to spend time with
them before school um by the time they
get home from school I'm I've typically
worked out a lot of my day already I'm
able to take a break with them until
they go to bed and then after they go to
bed I'll do a little bit more work so
I'd say if anybody has suffered from
lack of of time and attention is
probably uh marriage but that's what
happens when you have kids once you have
kids then it's like okay the adults have
to take the hit that's right so uh you
know speaking of well before we get to
that I want to talk about your mom
specifically but um not not you're on
your on the playground level your mom I
got some your mama jokes for you Ben uh
no seriously uh before we get there uh I
have a question for you so do you do
anything to keep grounded uh like
meditation do you do any meditation as
part of your ritual like besides prayer
which is obviously meditative prayer you
know is that I will say I'm not very
good at it uh I need to get better at
prayer uh probably the closest I get to
daily relaxation is just working out
which I try to do daily uh for an hour
probably uh and that's a good time for
me to sort of chill out and relax and
I'll listen to podcast or I'll listen to
music while I work out and and I find
that pretty calming um but you know
aside from praying which as I say I'm
I'm not particularly good at because I
think to be really good at prayer you
have to be able to as you say focus and
I mean as you know Orthodox Jews uh we
started off with pretty short prayers
and then they got longer and longer and
longer so it turns out that now in order
to get through shakas the the morning
prayer you have to bully your way
through you know 75 pages of of Hebrew
text so I can get through it pretty
quickly but that also does not help in
terms of like okay you know if you're
meditating you're meditating on one
thing and you're being on that one thing
for a particularly long period of time
just getting through that much text is
not super conducive to that yeah I was
going to ask you I had a live stream
with Rabbi David walpi from Sinai Temple
last week and I asked him you know I
said there's famous saying you know a
Jew can be angry at God a Jew can be
happy with God but a Jew can't be
without God I mean the very word Israel
means you know wrestles with God which
implies that at least you take god
seriously but my question to him and I
guess I'll make it to you too although I
suspect from what you just said it might
not be answerable by you is can you be a
Jew without prayer I mean I relate so
much more to Judaism through
intellectual through tment study
whatever than I do to it through prayer
it's just very difficult for me with the
high holidays coming up uh this week um
how do you how do you what do you think
do you think you can be a Jew without
prayer or or do you have to work at it
especially because it's hard for you so
I mean I should be working at it more
and I'll will admit to to a certain
amount of laziness that has set in uh
and that's something that I I definitely
need to work on but I think that we have
to separate off a couple things can you
be a Jew without Commandments or can you
be a Jew without being good at praying
so the reason that I pray is not because
I like praying or because I'm good at it
the reason that I pray is because I'm
commanded to right because that is one
of the Mis vote so I do not think that
you can be a Jew without adhering to
Commandments that you personally don't
enjoy that one definitely is requisite
um but can you be a Jew without being
good at praying sure I think that I
think that you can doesn't mean that
you're fulfilling Your Capacity is as
you know I'm sure I'm not but but I
agree with you I mean the stuff where I
tend to get a lot of meaning in Judaism
um is the is the study is the reading is
the insights maybe some of the social
stuff although I'm not super social as a
human being I'm the kind of guy who when
I go to SCH I will you know I tend to
dove in AE and then I will usually have
a safer I'll usually have a book with me
and I'll start reading the book and I'll
you know spend 20 minutes reading the
book and I generally feel like on an
emotional level and on an intellectual
level I tend to get more out of that
than the prayer but that's probably just
because I you know need to put more work
into my prayer which I'll as I say
freely acknowledge so uh the next
question I have for you actually
revolves around commandments so if you
you know could convince Jeremy boring
who you call the god king or whatever or
if you were God uh let's say which of
The Commandments would you get rid of
and you can't say adultery okay you
can't say adul I wasn't going to
honestly that one I don't find
particularly troubling yeah no no no
that one that one's actually like
there's some that that there's some that
obviously don't make tons of sense that
one seems to make a fair bit of sense to
me uh the the um you know uh all all the
strictures around kosro are are can be
pretty difficult particularly if you
travel a lot as you know so some of
those are are particularly difficult
honestly I I think that a lot of The
Commandments as originally articulated
in the Bible are a lot less honorous
than some of the rabbi practice that's
been stacked on top right there's this
old Jewish joke that it's it's now
several thousand years since the
revelation of Sinai and the Jews decide
they've had enough this deal has been
bad for them they decide that they're
going to get out of the deal so they
bring all the books they bring all the
spum they bring all the the tommo they
bring everything over to Mount Si and
they say to and they say to God and to
Moses we we don't want this anymore we
want to give all of this back and Moses
said what is all this I gave you five
books right and uh I think that there is
uh you know well while I adhere to the
Commandments there's certainly some
truth to that I mean it's become very in
some ways abstruse and and codified
that's not unusual that happens in
virtually every religion or legal system
but there are certain aspects that that
are that are difficult and honorous
honestly I don't find living an orthodox
lifestyle particularly onerous generally
I mean listen I live in a nice big
Jewish urban area there are lots of them
in the United States I can get good
restaurants I can eat good food my
wife's a good cook um I like Shabbat I
think Shabbat is a godsend literally so
that's you know that that doesn't bother
me too much yeah in terms of The
Commandments that you know I think are
are over overdone a lot of that would be
arguments that you know I would say that
many modern Orthodox Jews and and some
of uh the jts conservatives have had for
a long time like is chicken meat kind of
stuff and then conversely are there any
Commandments that you would add if you
were exercising your de deistic
propensities I I feel like we have
plenty okay hon to be honest with you I
feel I feel like the the 613 which is
the minimum and then the several
thousand that in practicality actually
are added on top I feel like we don't
have a dir of of Commandments I feel
like we're on top of that one yeah we we
have enough yeah I always say you know
people say I have trouble keeping the
Commandments I said did you sleep with
your mother-in-law recently and they
said no and I'm like all right you're
you're part way there you know you're
point you know 05% of the way there my
thumbs rather occupied right now holding
up good old Carl Sean but yours is free
to push that like button and don't
forget to subscribe it really helps us
with the algorithm now back to the
episode so you always say uh one of your
uh you know key you know characteristic
lines is turn about is fair play and I
want to uh start talking about the book
for a little bit this is of course your
what six seventh book now how to destroy
America in three easy steps um and I
want to talk to you about that because I
had a kind of a a question for you so
I'm thinking about writing a book based
on this and it's uh and it's about
destroying a country that was founded on
Divine principles with Divine leadership
with with uh with leaders that are
founding fathers that were you know are
basically worshiped and adored and uh
and that book's called had destroy North
Korea in three easy steps so what would
be the argument that you could make
against a disintegration is living in
North Korea as you call it their forces
between the unionist and the
disintegration it's very interesting
very provocative we can get into it but
um but I think centrally is this notion
that there's you know sort of a an
attribute of the United States that's
that's Divine and I wonder if you can
comment on that and why couldn't another
country make the same kind of divine
claims to its origin and therefore it
shouldn't be disintegrated when I I
believe I mean maybe controversial you
might want to get rid of North Korea at
least in its current stand Standing yeah
the North Korean government can can go
that's that's all right with me you know
if we are if we're talking about um you
know the divine origins of the United
States what I would say is that the I
don't think that the the origins of the
United States in terms of the
Declaration of Independence or the
Constitution were written by you know
people who were quote unquote divinely
inspired I think they were built on
thousands of years of intellectual
development in the judeo Christian West
and there are certain principles that
are embedded in the Declaration of
Independence that take their antecedence
obviously from those J Christian values
right when it says that all men are
created equal and doubt by their creator
certain inalienable rights these are all
ideas that have a long history in the
west I actually talk about this more at
length in my previous book right side of
History where I talk about sort of the
history of where a lot of these
Enlightenment ideas came from because I
I think there's a tendency particularly
in modern intellectual circles to draw a
complete gap between the Enlightenment
and what came before as though honestly
like there was some sort of divine
Enlightenment that happened and it was a
complete break with the past and that
that's not accurate I mean it's just not
accurate in any real historical or
intellectual sense so the the divine
inspiration for the United States would
have started a lot earlier and lay in
the combination of Greek reason and and
judeo-christian Ethos that Springs from
Sinai um the the principles of the
United States are good because they
acknowledge human nature and because
they are deliberately constructed in
order to AFF effectuate the best parts
of human nature and Tamp down the worst
parts of human nature that's that's why
the American system is good the American
system is is self-justifying not because
of Any appeal to Divine Authority it's
it's self-justifying because the
principles are indeed morally true and
descriptive of how human beings are and
should behave when you look at that and
you mentioned you know kind of the
intellectual influence in MO of
modernity in terms of our Scholars at
large and and one person that you uh
Reserve particular ire for in this book
is Howard Zin who was deeply influenced
of course by Nome Chomsky who was a
previous guest on the show and I thank
you and I point out you know I've I've
had people cancel coming on my show
because I've had on you know Dave Rubin
or somebody like that Michael shurmer uh
but I've never had you you or somebody
cancel coming on my show because I've
had on uh n chomski and again I keep my
show you know politically free because I
think you other people do a great job
pod save America if you want to listen
to politics or you can listen to the
Daily wire or listen to bench Pi show or
what have you but um but you mentioned
it and you mentioned in the book Howard
xan and om chonky and I wonder you know
thinking about it what the net effect of
that has been on on uh on the culture I
mean we you point out that many of our
departments not just you know history
departments on Modern campuses have this
book Howard zin's a popular History of
the United States which you know he was
kind of I don't know mutually
influential on on N Chomsky and so I
want to get your take is that sort of
irreversible I mean once something
reaches a a level of popularity it
becomes very deeply entrenched and now
it's being read in high schools Etc so
do you what level of impact on these
modern intellectual circles do you think
that the relatively recent up up um
upsurge of disintegration is history of
the United States if you will what
effect do you think that's having on on
University culture I mean tremendous
effect obviously the the sort of
disintegration is Viewpoint of Howard
Zin which is that the United States was
never rooted in fundamentally good
principles that the United States just
like many other societies but
particularly evily in the United States
was rooted in
heteropatriarchal racist
cisgender anti-woman nonsense uh that
that all of these various interest
groups were competing for Supremacy and
white supremacy lay at the root of the
United States I mean you've seen this
bleed into the 1619 project you've seen
Howard perspective on American history
which of course begins with uh the
arrival of Christopher Columbus in the
so-called new world uh he begins his
book talking about the evils of
Christopher Columbus you've seen
obviously the the focus on tearing down
Columbus statues around the United
States in the middle of this sort of
historical reenvisioning and rewriting
it's had a pretty deep impact again it
comes from a sort of marxist materialist
point of view which that the United
States is not in any way rooted in
principle that all of the United
States's history is really just cover
for exploitation and that the only
solution for exploitation is to tear
down those systems and put in place
quote unquote fairer more Marxist
systems uh I think it's a complete
misread of American History I think that
it relies on an awful lot of eliding of
evidence it's not posited as a
corrective to whitewashed history which
I would kind of accept right I mean if
if you're talking about American history
has historically been seen in too
positive a fashion right it ignored too
much the mistreatment of Native
Americans and black Americans and women
that's totally fair I if you want to
talk about how we can correct that that
history that's fine but if you want to
say that the root of American history
lies in evil that is absolutely ignorant
and counter to prevailing evidence
because the fact is that all of the
things that we've talked about what that
you're talking about here you know
racism and sexism and bigotry and
homophobia all these things are present
in nearly every society in all of human
history what's different about the
United States is what's different about
the United States and so focusing on the
the evils of humanity as Manifest in the
United States as unique to the United
States but all the good things about the
United States as sort of universal to
humanity runs completely counter to all
available evidence so given that and um
you know your book brainwashed which is
about your experiences and thoughts uh
as a younger person much younger person
as one was might have been one of your
first books it was my first yeah 19 when
I wrote it yeah yeah and you talk about
what the university experience was like
at UCLA of course it wasn't as as
anywhere comparable to what you'd get at
UC San Diego but nevertheless um if you
were to create actually Shapiro
University what would that look like
what would be the required curriculum at
shapir University so I think obviously
you'd have actually read some Classics
of Western literature uh and I think
that that would be judged based on the
importance of the literature over the
course of history so it wouldn't be
based on any sort of quota system for
the race or sex of the author I think
that's silliness of the highest order I
think that Aristotle happens to be a
more important thinker than James
Baldwin that that is not a degradation
to James Baldwin I think Aristotle is is
more of an important think than nearly
everybody right so you know pointing out
that that you only have a certain amount
of time a curriculum that included both
of those people would probably be a good
thing um but I think that if you have to
prioritize then you prioritize the the
most important thoughts in human history
rather than prioritizing the silliness
of of Jac Dera or the Ridiculousness of
her the the attempt to quota your way to
a good education is really really stupid
because what's inside your head matters
much more than the color of the skin on
the outside of your head sticking with
the book theme your next book I think
was a book that you wrote with your
father uh and involving of all subjects
the white socks um so I want to ask you
if you wrote book with your mother you
talk talk a lot about your relationship
with your father but a little less so
about your mother if you were to write a
book with your mother what would that be
about probably practical living my mom
happens to be the most practical person
I know like she's very Tas like she's
very down to earth something needs to
get done how do you go about doing it
and my dad tends to be much more of a
dreamer much more kind of visionary and
his like he's the one who would talk
politics with me and my mom be the one
like okay now you got to sit down and
you got to do X Y and Z how do we
actually get that done and so you sort
of making practical tips for living
would be sort of more my mom's my mom's
game also sort of along that them theme
in terms of culture Etc within the you
know shapira University Universe uh what
would the role of you know cultural
things uh Hollywood I always point out
you know the budget for Hollywood
blockbuster movies about space or aliens
or whatever is like 10 times the budget
of NASA and you know why does why does
Hollywood it's actually if you take how
much you know Hollywood contributes to
the GDP it's a lot I mean it's maybe a
hundred billion dollars or something
like that it's pretty good but that's
like what Apple has in cash you know a
Wednesday so why do you think Hollywood
has such a big influence on culture and
uh and then I'll ask a followup just
about uh the influence that science that
science fiction has had on you in in
particular obviously you know as you
mentioned earlier attention is is the
key commodity so people spend an awful
lot of their time being attentive to
Hollywood product human beings are
storytelling animals and Hollywood tells
stories in a way that not only is easy
to to comprehend unless it's the latest
Nolan film apparently um but but also uh
in in a way that is somewhat addictive I
mean images tend to be addictive to the
human brain in a way that words are not
which is why we are stupider culture now
than we were 100 years ago or 150 years
ago when people tended to read a lot
more often it's also why people you know
when they watch the news tend to jump to
conclusions a lot more frequently than
actually if they read the story um but
that that's yeah that's why Hollywood is
so impactful and it's why it matters the
kind of material that that Hollywood
puts out there as far as science fiction
yeah I'm a huge sci-fi fan I've always
been a huge sci-fi fan so I've read I
can't imagine the there's much classic
Sci-fi that I haven't read um and
there's some good news sci-fi that's
come out ranging from sort of the action
genre to sort of the more the more
thinky sort of stuff yeah I no I really
enjoy sci-fi because again it you can
explore both moral issues and
technological issues outside the
confines of a lot of the dictates that
that exist in normal literature where
you know you can be you're not going to
be accused of uh violating certain tabos
uh if you're writing in a theoretical
universe as opposed to you know writing
in the Practical one yeah I think i' I
had this conversation with Dave Rubin in
connection to the Great Book Fahrenheit
451 obviously relevant to his book don't
burn this book directly relevant and we
kind of you know came to the conclusion
that you know science fiction allows you
to kind of pregame or have thought
conduct thought experiments as we
physicists say Duncan experiments about
the future in a way that's really uh
unique important and unusual so I want
to ask you if you were a science fiction
hero or if you were a superhero DC
Comics fan that you are uh what would be
your superpower what is your besides
amazing you know reducing your height a
little bit cuz you know you don't want
to get too tall right so so what would
be your your superpower if I could
choose one obviously uh physical
invulnerability would be a pretty good
one I feel like Superman style physical
one uh but yeah trying to think about
you know super speed would probably be
pretty fun but I feel like that's just
like I I feel like I can wait on a plane
and do some reading it's not that bad
I've asked this a many people and I kind
of see a difference between how a
scientist answers this question and a
non-scientist answers this question if I
could give you a pill one of my Sons is
working on a pill called The Never Dying
pill which will undoubtedly win him a
Nobel Prize ironically not his father uh
but if you could take a Never Dying pill
and only you you can't you can't give it
to everyone you know uh would you take
it you know you'd be in same Health you
are now 35 or so years old Peak physical
condition of Donna select physique would
you take such a pill I mean the only
militating factors against it would be
uh the wife and kids that that's
literally the only militating Factor
against it but yes I mean sure I'm
fascinated by people who uh who get
bored with the world is a pretty
interesting place uh and uh there's
always new stuff happening and new
things to find out so yeah I mean a
longer time span means more things I can
spend my attention on so abely that's
actually so you know you are in harmony
with many scientists who want to see
what physical laws will be like in the
year 2200 um but going ahead just a few
uh more days a few fewer days than that
I want to ask you uh first of all a lot
of my friends you know can't really vote
for Trump I mean it's no surprise on a
campus like this I don't want to get too
political I don't get really political
at all but what do you say to someone
who can't vote for Trump and can't vote
for Biden and just kind of in the middle
what do they do is it is it like
flipping a coin what should such a
person do who's who's not like a rabid
political animal but just feels like
we're in this we're in this zone right
now and neither one is particularly
palatable to them I mean I hear you I
didn't vote at the top of the ticket
last time around so I get it I mean
seriously like I I I I don't think that
it's a moral failing not to vote or to
vote only below the top of the ticket
there's two ways of viewing your vote
right this is what I said last time
around there is a way viewing your vote
where it is just you know a coupon that
expires tomorrow so you may as well use
it because who cares right it's a Burger
King coupon it goes away the day after
the election it's irrelevant uh or there
is the idea that your vote is a is some
sort of moral judgment upon you in which
case you have to decide whether that
vote is actually a moral judgment that's
made about you because you are giving
the green light to the character of the
person to whom you're voting or because
you are voting in favor of the program
the person stands for so if if you
believe that it's a referendum on
character you can vote that way if you
believe that it is a referendum on the
political program you can vote that way
as well I tend to be pretty tolerant in
how people cast their votes because I
think that there there are a lot of fair
arguments about what a vote should
represent but um being dissatisfied with
the current state of our politics I
think uh is is certainly not uh uncalled
for given how things are going I feel
like you are you know critical of
President Obama I mean you've you've
been on the record of of critiquing him
and your feelings about him but I don't
I don't to ask you about him
specifically uh but but more The Meta
question which he was the first black
president it was a huge precedent for
America uh and I remember feeling like
we had turned a corner I wonder do you
think it's a good idea for a Jew to be
president uh because uh does it not you
know carry with it this unrealistic
weight that the person you know he or
she would be a representative of all the
members of that particular you know in
this case Faith group so honestly the
reason that I thought it would be good
for America to have a black president
would be if the president had then
brought down the temperature in terms of
raal polarization which was sort of the
inherent promise and implicit promise of
the Obama campaign it didn't end up
materializing and so as to whether a Jew
should be president I don't care I
really don't I mean I don't care whether
a black person's president or a Jew is
President I don't I don't care about any
of the the features of the person who's
President other than you know their
character and uh and what sort of
policies they effectuate so do I think
that it would be a particularly bad
thing for a Jew to be president not
especially I think how they represent
themselves as a Jew matters to me as a
Jew right if if you get somebody like a
Bernie Sanders and he says I'm the first
Jewish president and it's like okay yeah
but what do you do that is Jewish and
his answer is I once had a mat ball like
I I find that particularly compelling in
terms of him being the quote unquote
first Jewish president so he's born
ethnically Jewish whatever man um as it
says more about America's willingness to
elect people of all different
backgrounds which says something good
about Americans generally but I I I've
never expected you know Barack Obama to
be a standing for all black Americans or
anything I I always expected Barack
Obama actually to be a a rational
individual and I was disappointed when I
thought that he reverted to a certain
level of tribal politics what do you
think if uh president Shapiro came about
uh Ben Shapiro came about um what would
you want to enact in your first 100 days
in office well I would be the first
president in in modern American history
to completely destroy the executive
branch I mean I would I would eviscerate
the executive branch I'd fire nearly
everybody and then I would force the and
then I'd Force Congress to pass very
specific laws dealing with what it was
they wanted to do as opposed to kicking
all legislative and policy-making
priorities over to the executive branch
I'd get rid of the Department of
Education and two other departments that
Rick Perry can't name there there' be
there would be a lot of cuts lot of cuts
over at the uh at the federal government
level uh and I think that is perfectly
appropriate the president basically has
two jobs one is to you know keep the
nation safe ensure that the laws are
Faithfully executed and the other is the
educational job and I would spend an
awful lot of time trying to educate the
American public I think about founding
principles doing a lot of the same
things that I try to do on a daily basis
just you know from the seat of the of
the White House again this is one of the
divides I've had about President Trump I
like a lot of his policy I think he's
done a terrible job on the educational
front trying to teach people what
government is what should do and what he
expects of the country and what what he
should do so I I would I would spend a
lot more time on the second facet I
think Barack Obama spent a lot of time
on that facet he just said things I
disagree with um and he grew the
executive branch massively but it's one
of the reasons why I don't really want
to be president because frankly I think
I get to do a lot of the fun stuff
without having to do a lot of the boring
stuff yeah you'd uh you might you might
have a nicer uh you know ride to show
for you around and called Air Force One
um so I want to ask you a couple
question you're used to asking people
questions on the Sunday special I was
honored to be on it couple about a year
ago exactly but I want to ask you what's
the one question you wish you would be
asked by somebody in an interview show
such as this I suppose that I I uh wish
that somebody would ask me uh whether I
actually care about uh about other
individual human beings like that
because the perception is so wildly
different from what is the reality of
course you know when you're in politics
you spend a lot of time talking as you
should about broad broad public policy
that infuses you know all of that that
encompasses a lot of individual human
beings and and so you have to make
policy uh that is the best for as many
human beings as humanly possible without
violating the rights of anybody um but
do I do I care about you know people who
are negatively affected by policies that
I talk about of course I mean and and
the basic notion in politics is that if
I'm not directing a government policy at
helping ex person is because I don't
care about ex- person well maybe I do
maybe I think that the policy that I'm
AFF effectuating is better for that
person or maybe I think that there are
non-governmental things that can be done
to help that person that are more
important than using the government as
sort of a broad Club in order to achieve
particular policy end the government is
a blunderbus and I think that most human
interactions are scalpel and and ought
to be done at that level and follow up
to that is what's the most misunderstood
thing about you other than you're the
president of the SEI Valley cardi B fan
club I think there's this weird
perception online uh from people who've
never watched the show uh that I'm
incredibly serious all the time which
means they've never actually watched the
show and that that's somewhat irritating
to me I mean the cardi B thing plays
into it that's a that's a 10-minute long
comedic segment on my show and there's
been this attemp by by some folks on the
on the left to paint me as some sort of
scolding personality who's just there to
to be you know angry at you all the time
and that's always weird I've never
really understood that frankly because I
think you watch one episode of the show
and you're not going to get that okay so
let's move into the rapid fire questions
and for extra credit I urge the audience
to set the podcast on twox speed uh so
first of all um are you a techno
Optimist would you sign up for a trip to
Mars or a neuralink chip to be embedded
into your brain so you can commune with
the haer and uh like Elon Musk is having
us do would you would you accept such a
chip implanted into your brain or take a
trip to Mars how well prove none of the
Technologies so far not so good but if
you got a letter from from God and says
you're not going to die on this trip to
Mars you might die on Mars but would you
take the trip are you an adventurous
person in that sense would you take the
Chip And planted in your brain uh what
can it allow me to do instantaneous
recall uh you can you know rap like
cardi B anytime you want you can ter I
mean the ladder sounds terrible like
that that would that would cause a
significant reduction in my lingual
abilities so I'm not I'm not super into
that but but as far as instant recall
and all that yeah no I think that I'd
probably I'd probably do it I mean I I'm
I'm a techno Optimist I don't think the
technology is particularly threatening
and I think it's enhanced nearly every
facet of human life I see you as sort of
the most uh optimistic pessimist that I
know uh but what are you really
optimistic about uh what kind of thing
gives you optimism for the future human
ability to solve problems the thing that
we've apparently forgotten completely
about and thus must take drastic action
in order to prevent uh the uh the
progressive abilities of human beings to
solve problems it makes me absolutely
nuts when you know folks take climate
change as an example I I think climate
change is happening I think the evidence
shows climate change is happening I
think the majority of it is caused by
human activity um but I am not of the
belief that you shut down all industry
across the world or tax it out of
existence in order to stop climate
change I think human beings have an
unbelievably great ability to adapt and
to create new products and services it
seems like so much of public life is
rooted in the assumption that human
beings are never going to be able to
create our way out of this one which is
a weird thing to say since human beings
have literally been creating their way
out of problems for all of human history
and that's really accelerated in the
last two to three hundred years when you
look at that you look at the progress
though it comes with a downside too and
some say things like artificial
intelligence will lead to kind of this
dystopian future where we're effectively
going to subvert you know all of our
needs and to machines and machine
learning and there'll be less
opportunities for employment Etc you
talked to um to uh uh Andre Yang about
that um but the the question I have for
you now is like what do you think about
these kind of ultimate extensions of
that possibly seeming like science
fiction now so-called simulation
hypothesis that we're actually the
result of a simulation being run on a
you know on a Pentium processor of the
year you know 2700 that progress that
you talk about comes with a downside
crisper Gene modification all sorts of
things and in that way techno optimism
uh specifically can cause you know
potentially these dystopian scenarios
but I want to ask you specifically have
you heard of the simulation hypothesis
that we are effectively the simulation
of this ultimate artificial intelligence
sometime in the future I've heard the
hypothesis there there's as there's
there's no evidence to back it so far as
I'm aware so it's as much of a faith
statement as as a belief in God with
actually I would say maybe significantly
less evidence than the idea of a of a
guy I mean it is just a form of a god
hypothesis just from in different guys
it seems I mean given how crappy this
year has been maybe that's right the
simulation has a few bugs we got to
reboot it and I would ask you know the
simulators you know why why are there so
many Kardashians you know that's kind of
question I would ask um so you've
already had me on your show so who's
your dream guest in in the future who
would you most like to have that's alive
and then I'll ask you dead but first
alive who who's who's like your dream
get or or one of the two or three you
don't have to narrow it down but who who
would you most like to have a
conversation with present company
excluded that you haven't yet well we
we've been trying to book Thomas soul
for a long time he's been a big hero of
mine frankly I think it would be
interesting to have a conversation with
Barack Obama because I quiz him on some
stuff I think he's an interesting
thinker I just think that he uh I think
that he dumbs down what he actually
thinks for for public consumption a lot
of the time and uh I I would understand
him not being too fond of the idea of
getting on camera with me give him some
of the things that I've said about his
presidency in the past um the uh
Benjamin Netanyahu prime minister of
Israel we've tried to book that I think
we probably will sometime this year so
you know there honestly there are a lot
of people who I like talking to I don't
think would make a great special um but
are just interesting human beings whose
books I've read and usually that happens
on a one-off basis I read somebody's
book I think it's interesting and then I
want to talk to them and very often I'll
reach out to them on a one level and
we'll actually have conversations that
way and I tend to use them as sort of
expert resources on particular topics so
it may not sustain like a full hour
conversation the reason that you'd want
you know prominent figures is because
they have interesting life histories and
interesting stories to tell but in terms
of exploration of ideas um you know it's
uh I would say that I've had an
opportunity to talk with a lot of those
people just not all of it's public so uh
next question and revolves around your
social media presence and that is the
following uh you've got 3.1 million
followers on Twitter
um you got millions of followers on
Facebook online elsewhere but you know
as I said to you in person when we met
about a year ago I I said there's this F
famous vignette from Animal Farm where
the the pig says to the donkey uh
Benjamin your namesake Benjamin the
donkey the pig says to the donkey you've
got such a nice tail and I only have
this short little curly thing and the
donkey says yeah the God God gave me the
tail to keep away the Flies uh but I'd
rather not have the Flies and not need
the tail so I guess my questions could
be summarized you know if you could go
time traveling backwards kill baby
Twitter uh you know would you do it is
there a downside to this to this to this
statue that you've achieved well I mean
there's certainly downsides to to uh
being you know wellknown uh and those
downsides range from safety concerns to
taking enormous amounts of abuse every
three weeks when I TR on Twitter and
it's literally on the dot every three
weeks I know what's going on with their
algorithm or maybe I just say something
dumb every three weeks whichever but in
any case you know there there are
obviously downsides to it um I I think
of all the apps Twitter is the most
damaging because Twitter uh is built for
onliners and then it went from a place
where everybody sort of joked and
understood it was built for onliners to
a place where you were supposed to
perform serious discourse in on liners
which is not possible so I think what it
started off as and what it morphed what
it started off as was fine and basically
innocuous and what it morphed into is
something that's really really damaging
especially now that it's like okay we're
going to go back to
2011 and we're going to dig up a joke
tweet that you sent and we're going to
destroy you and that's for everybody
right we're going to completely pretend
that what was essentially a a repository
for making dum jokes was actually the
same as it is now which is vetted
political statements being put out in
240 character increments right and that
that's that's very Sil I've had people
cancel you know unfollow me unfriend me
whatever because I was on your show um
and I think that kind of you know delies
a certain type of simplemindedness you
know I'm not inviting everybody to
unfollow Etc but I do think it has had a
pernicious effect on the culture it's
almost become a part of almost Hollywood
Silicon Valley kind of Nexus of
influence that's so outsized I want to
go to a positive thing right now uh why
do you why do you play the violin what
does that mean to you do you is it
something that you feel God's presence
the most you know oftentimes I ask
people where do you feel God's oh when
my child was born I'm like okay well
that was once or you know if you're
lucky more than once or even if you're
lucky once a lot of people can't
experience do you feel God's presence
through music through listening more
than playing because I hear my own flaws
when I play just as in every part of my
job um when whenever I do something I
tend to be my own toughest critic and so
I tend to hear the part where I'm
playing that don't sound as good as they
should I mean I play because I've been
playing since I was five and I enjoy
making music with my father and it's he
he plays piano he's a professional
pianist and so we can play Brahms
together and uh and that's wonderful and
enjoyable my kids really love it and
when you're really into it it's you know
you feel a certain flow a psychological
flow that's that's quite good for you
mentally uh where where I see God the
most in my life is is obviously in my
kids uh and it's not just in their birth
it's how they act it's how they see the
world it's how they interact with each
other um and spending a Shabbat and
watching them play on the floor with
each other is pretty much as close to
Heaven as I think you're going to get in
this lifetime I always say kids are the
only proven form of time travel it's
just you don't get to go with them into
the deep future but they're you carry
their mote or shaped by you and that
actually will live on to the Future all
right that brings us to the very end
questions there's just three left to go
Ben first question I ask all my guests
I'm G to ask you um can you provide for
us in you know 30 seconds or less a
geometric quantization of space and time
that also involves relativistic uh
properties of the Hadron particles 42
right you got it I've asked Nobel Prize
winners they can't get that okay so as
you know in Judaism there's a concept of
what's called an ethical will a Zava and
and that's sort of a uh bequeathing of
one's ethical and wisdom values rather
than their monetary Acquisitions or
material
Acquisitions I know those will all go to
uh to uh you know good causes I'm sure
but but in this case I want to know what
would be in your Zava your ethical will
what kinds of wisdom or or Mor you want
to leave to your children and and those
of us or those out there who are your
ideological children in a sense well I
mean the the the sukim the verses from
Deuteronomy where it describes choosing
life and that the choice is in your
hands that's paraa very good that's myth
that's my birthday that to me the key
aspect of human living is recognizing
that most choice about your own life is
in your hands doesn't mean everything
obviously health is not in your hands in
many cases and and sometimes wealth um
but uh most of the choices that you make
toward happiness or non-ha in your life
are in your own hands and that that
comes with an awful you know lot of
responsibility but also an awful lot of
freedom and those two are balanced the
freedom and the responsibility are
balanced I think as a society we've
tried to maximize the freedom and reduce
the responsibility but I don't think you
can do that I think they're two sides of
the same coin The More You Want to Be
Free the more you have to take
responsibility for your decisions and
conversely the more responsibility you
take on your shoulders the more free you
are to actually act within your own life
I want to ask you about uh going also
into the future in sort of a time capsu
question but first a word from our
sponsors which is cardi B rap
microphones courtesy no no actually
don't have any sponsors and I likely
won't after this interview which is this
bucket and this mop sponsored by cardi
okay hey we're not going to get uh we're
not going to get into that aspect of the
culture very good Ben okay next question
involves science fiction and so the into
the impossible podcast is named after
one of Sir Arthur C Clark's famous Three
Laws the first one being any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic the second
one being for every expert there's an
equal and opposite expert but the third
one is the only way to find out uh what
is possible is to venture a little bit
into the impossible so now going
backwards in time I want to ask you what
thing or achievement or whatever seemed
impossible to a young Ben ship hero
20-year-old Ben shipiro but now since
you had the courage which I think is one
of your dominant traits you have an
incredible amount of Courage you went
into the impossible and you did it so
what thing in the past would you tell
yourself have this courage go forward
what seems impossible will become
possible honestly I think that the the
one thing that I would tell myself as a
young person uh is is I've never had a
I've never been shy so that was never
something I had to advise myself to to
Sherk with the shyness to me it would be
uh have the courage to question your own
assumptions and your own opinions uh and
don't be quite so sure of what it is
that you're saying and take a look at
all sides I hope that's something I've
gotten better at the course over the
course of my career and I hope that
people can you know if you listen to the
show but or if you read my writings you
can hear me kind of turning over points
before I immediately come to a
conclusion okay couple more rapid fire
would you rather win a Nobel Peace Prize
or a Pulitzer Prize just quick answers
oh God they're so degraded honestly I'd
rather have a $5 cup of coffee than
either so would you rather write a Torah
commentary or a tment commentary Torah
commentary and uh what would you say to
uh like Hill said uh you know the secret
to Torah is secret to the Torah is is
don't do something unpleasant to your
neighbor that you find un unpleasant
yourself what's kind of your teaching or
conversion on one leg so to speak I
think I've already said it uh the that
your life is in your hands and so make
choices that are most likely to maximize
success for yourself and for those you
care about okay Ben ship well last
question if you'll indulge me 10 more
seconds let's say daily wire goes off
the air the internet Gets Zapped uh you
have to start all over what what would
you do you have no Twitter no Facebook I
mean it would be like a paradise
apparently what would you do differently
besides you know maybe learning to code
or or or whatever you guys would do I
don't know um I mean I I enjoy my life
so much I get to speak about topics I
care about and write about topics I care
about so if if all that went away I'd go
back to what I was doing before which
was doing all that anonymously right
before I was famous doing this stuff I
was not famous doing this stuff so I
would continue to do a lot of that stuff
or maybe I'd go to to medical school my
my wife seems to honestly it seems kind
of cool okay Ben thank you for all the
wonderful uh influence you've had on the
World to the good which I think is very
very important so thank you Ben shanat
TOA shanat TOA thanks so much